yes
okay for people who are joining this
live stream we are talking about
control systems and preparation for
version 12.3 of wolverine language
and we're just starting to talk about
connecting our control systems
capabilities to machine learning
and connecting system modeler to control
systems and machine learning
and so on so we're not going to talk
about machine learning today
okay but we've got so what where do i
start here
okay so the the thing so let me just
describe the overall workflow so we
understand that
so the typical workflow one important
reason
to model something is because you want
to control
it in engine when it comes to
engineering systems
uh and the like the typical workflow
that you then do is that you need to
build a model in the control
context that model of the thing you
control is always called
a plant model okay
i suppose whatever it is as opposed to
an animal model no i'm not a joking
like chemical plant regardless of
whether it's a rocket or
or what it is okay
there's some things you need to do there
but then the typical workflow is that
you're going to linearize that model
because you're gonna then design a
controller using linear design
techniques
there are non-linear design techniques
but they're much less mature
and the one that's sort of robust and
works well are linear design techniques
okay so in other words if you're if your
plant stays within the linear regime
you're in good shape
if the thing goes nonlinear you're
screwed basically
sort of there there's things that
happens when you use feedback that tends
to keep you in that regime
so it works remarkably much better than
than
than you think yeah again nevertheless
there are issues that you that you know
your typical boeing 737 or whatnot
will have several dozen of these in
different parts
of your flight envelope
okay but but this makes it easy to go
from system modeler
linearizer plan do your control design
but then it was super complicated to get
something back
into system modeler because these
control functions returned all kinds of
different things
special things that you then needed to
specially do
something with right okay
so there was a lot of do-it-yourself uh
work
to try to get it was all doable so
just so i'm clear when you have a
controller like a pid controller or
something
can i can i see what is our what is our
version of that what's it called
pid pid tune
pid what tune the second one
yes
okay so this gives a pid controller
and the way it is connected back is in
the details and options
so no no but i'm just trying to
understand what
comes in and what goes out when you have
one of these controllers a plant model
goes in and the controller comes out
okay so but wait a second so this is an
example of a
a pid controller this thing here yes
okay so if i take that thing and i just
say
uh
okay so i did take this now what do i do
with this what can i do with this
yes so earlier you know you you had to
use the function systems model feedback
connect
to connect it back to the plant and
that's the i want to connect to the
plant i just want to see the thing
i don't i'm much more clueless than that
yeah so
the controller doesn't work by itself it
has to be joined together with the plant
which open the detail section stephen
you can see conceptually what the heck
goes on see the
the the gfb there that's the that's the
controller
okay but but but i mean if i were
thinking about this like a
layer and a neural net or some such
other thing i've got an eft coming in
and the u of t coming out
so how would i actually given this
object how do i feed in an eft
oh you you would do um output response
so you would you'd use output response
and give the et signal
whatever okay so so what could my signal
be sine sine t or something yeah
sine t and then do i go comma t or
something like that yeah you can give
comma t
to try to do it symbolically or yeah
okay and so what this means is
i'm just trying to understand what this
means this means
you have this controller you're wiggling
the input to this thing
and this is the output it's producing is
that correct yeah if that is the input
this is the output but we are actually
wiggling r
of t the one before that
yes and understand where there's some
feedback loop here
exactly so what you want to do is to
change the user interface to that system
to that plant
you see what i'm saying so so normally
if the input
would have gone directly into the
alice's thing
now the input is the rt that goes into
the
the controller connected to your system
okay i'm saying
what you're saying what what is elsa's
that's the plant model
that's that's the thing that was you
yeah
that you used to design the pid that's
the linear system
l-system system yes okay
okay so that's the original system the
plant model
now we're gonna think of this sort of
hooked up
like like it is here with a controller
those other signals
dtmt and so on those are disturbances
that act on your system so for instance
if it's a cruise controller for your car
that could be a hill that's not modeled
that could be wind
okay okay and the goal for the
controller is to reject
to cancel out those disturbances that
are not modeled
so that even if there's a hill going up
you still keep it at 60 miles an hour
see that's a very good example so the
when we are doing manual speed control
the input to the system is the gas pedal
but when we are doing cruise control
the input to the system is the speed we
set at a set point
you know
exactly okay okay i understand
all right okay so now okay i get the
basic setup so now what
what is new here so what's new is that
we've provided so this pid tune had a
really good idea in it
that we basically generalized to all
control systems
which is that it can give you um a data
object out from which you can get all
the possible
transfer functions that you might want
to get
so how does it how do you get the later
object from pid tune
yeah that's the last yeah we have to
give that's in uh if you look at scope
probably there's an example there but
but you had to give another argument to
give for
go to properties
yeah there's that example pid data and
it'll give you that data object
which we have now generalized to systems
model controller data
and plan to make pid data obsolete
hold on hold on hold on so what this one
gives you
is access to
many more things in that graph so why
isn't this just information
what what what information well the the
function
information there's nothing more there
it is what you see no i understand that
why do i how do i get
what i'm supposed to be getting from
here oh
you get it from pid tune uh if you
evaluate pid tune
uh if you evaluate that you'll now get
that systems model controller data
if you are in the prototype build just
to evaluate that example
this one here not not this one where you
had the pid data input yeah then
i thought you told me that the pid data
was about to be obsolete
yeah but if you it will still work so
just i don't want to see what the past i
want to see the future what
then go to pid to new yeah it'll give
you the future right now
because it it's backward compatible
that's what i meant that's why i
mentioned
this page is just it's just the same as
that yeah
so i don't understand what is the
proposed design
the proposed design is to allow this
returning this systems model control
data
is what allows us to give a clean word
is that what this system their control
this is no this is a
this is an easy use case that just gives
okay raw
database where's the use case where
you're giving back the fancy thing
so just yes that example is right here
so if you copy that what you had before
yeah copy that and evaluate it
because instead of pid data we'll
observe that and now people will just
give systems model controller data
where do they give that instead of pid
data
oh why so this giant long thing yeah
that
we give we support pid data for back but
why why is it not just called data or
something
why does it need to be systems model
whatever because
it's a system symbol now
i don't understand this is a string yeah
the input there
okay
yeah i mean the string could be shorter
is that what you mean yes that's what i
mean
okay systems model controller data
that's the head for that that template i
mean the
the output i see
and and why is it exactly that this
thing here
that if i say information of that thing
there that i can't get something like
this out
there is only the transfer function
so this is the one which has everything
yes
okay okay
okay so so what i'm saying here
let's see what do you want to do here
you want to say so the default
is still to just produce a transfer
function is that correct
yeah it's kind of like getting immediate
data out
but it's not everything you need
you know depending on your what you your
workflow
right but so what i'm thinking is i
don't know the data is the right term
but
systems model controller data
i mean in a sense
make more sense to at least just at
least just call it that i would think
i agree i think that's a better name
okay
okay fine all right so okay so you've
got this thing out now
now i can wire that up if that if you
if um no now with that you can ask all
kinds of properties now you can ask for
that original controller
using the name of that controller is
feedback
okay so i can say percent three sub
is there a data set here yes property
data set why is it not listed in the
list of properties here
it should be it's called property data
set
but that's wrong it should be called
data set because that's what it is for
everything
oh okay the ones
and i don't even see property data set
here unless i can't unless i'm not
spelling it correctly no yes
okay i think i missed that design
because one of the functions i looked
what function did you look at i forget
which one but i design my functions like
this with property data set and property
association
that's not right i think it should be i
mean the way it works for entities
at least it's just data set okay i'll
yeah i i looked at something else and
had this like this property data set and
uh okay
i'll i'll okay all right
um okay so this is
i don't i don't understand what these
things mean but this is um
yes so all these refer to different
aspects in that details and section
in that block diagram okay
and and where can i get can i get the
block diagram is there a block diagram
version that i could see here yeah the
block diagram is right now just in the
details and options
no no no no no no there isn't one there
isn't
well so i'm asking like for neural nets
we went to a lot of trouble to actually
have it be the case
that we don't have that for control
we never designed that would it be a
good idea
yes it is a good idea to actually see it
yeah but it's it's some work
too but i mean so roughly what what
you're saying is
in one of these systems you you can
describe one of these systems
symbolically
in the control system framework right
yes
i see and so then there's a question of
that symbolic description right now
just has some textual thing like this
right but when the the one thing to
remember the the original
work done on control systems it never
preserved the structure it never
preserved the graph structure it always
reduced to a new canonical form
so it was always gone i see what i'm
saying
they were just all just get it
right when you use system systems model
controller data yes and then if you ask
if you use pid
directly then it will flatten it right
yes when you ask pid directly it just
returns
one of those properties in that data
object
i i get it i get it i get it i get it um
why is it called systems model
controller data as opposed to systems
model controller
i guess because it's it's more than that
than the controller yeah the controller
is just one property and should it be
called
controller data or controller
information
based on our other use of the term
information
i mean historically we you we called all
these things data
because it was pid data no but but also
in all kinds of other areas we've called
them all pid data was the
was the location function okay all right
okay
okay so there's a lot of things that you
want to find out for instance
how powerful is my systems
in its ability to reject disturbances
like how big of a hill can you hit with
your car before it start you know and it
still keeps the speed up
yep it's like good to know yes
so yeah so all of those things are
available in that object
that's another transfer function that
goes from
uh that tells you you know basically how
how much those things are so
what are these here this is estimator
regulator
so these are all functions
you should look at the new ones here
you have to look at the new pages i know
these are old functions that have been
upgraded
with this ability to do what to generate
the property by the way
to generate the property and now it also
directly supports system model
the from system modeler
so now we automatically that's a
different thing that you're you're
describing here
so if what you're telling me is that if
i do this instead of controller data
why am i getting why is it why is it
spinning my disk
why is it well is there something
dynamic here what's going on
no there's nothing dynamic there well
there's something wrong because it was
spinning
you know it was doing a not ready type
spinning thing here for the formatting
of this
which seems very suspicious okay so
you're saying if i say
system model here no no no if you give
the system model as the first
argument if there's a system model
object as the first argument
okay so so let me guess a system model
object go to connect system model
controller
and there you'll get examples that work
because otherwise
normally any model no most models are
not controllable
think about it yourself you're modeling
a system you don't want any unknown
input to it
you want it to be able to be simulated
as is
yes but so there has to be some
stochastic
input yeah or controllable input
like like if you have an inverted
pendulum what is it that you can control
what is it that you can affect right we
have to point that out
so here's a here's a simple engine you
know it's like a dc motor
okay so if i now say system model just
just so i'm
understanding uh
why is this called systems model
i don't understand it should be system
model controller data
but we're taking off the systems model
anyway but why was it systems plural
model
do you understand yeah it goes back to
the naming differences between control
and system model
okay but it's wrong right so let's
alight it
by just saying controller data is there
anywhere else where you're using systems
plural model
yes all the control system functions as
systems model
where
the ones that were designed for version
seven and eight and no but
what are they called they're all like
systems models series connect systems
model paddle connect
okay but boy that's a mess
okay so if i say control systems
if you look at model connections okay so
we've got a mess here we've got a mess
how do these relate to the system model
the the modern system model things
are they compatible or not
so they're not they
work on transfer functions and state
space models
oh my god
but they can be they can be injected
into
a you know system modeler yeah it's like
a subset of
one way to create models is to create
from this class of models
so these are like special models
special i understand i understand but
then then
okay so so i understand here okay so
we've got our dc motor
okay so now we've got a singular system
model linearized
oh come on this is this is crazy this is
crazy
what's this what's this what's this
about
that's just a bug right yeah no no no
that's not no it's a bug it shouldn't be
there
it shouldn't be a context function that
was because
well it will won't be there in the
future but that's the way they are
developing it so has to do with branches
and prototype
okay all right i understand not a
problem
all right so now okay so let's look at
this so this is now taking this model
and linearizing it so for example could
i plot
the unlinearized model wow okay by the
way that
that progress dialogue does not follow
the modern standard
no it will be updated for 13.
okay okay so could i for example plot
if i do system model plot
yes of percent eight
what the heck is this what's that weird
stuff what is that
what's that what is that
so in 2.2
captions were introduced in system
modeler and i'm sorry i'm which
and 12.2 in version 12.2
that was never reviewed that was never
reviewed and they're wrong
what the heck are you doing here
okay that's that's just wrong right
what is it doing in some weird courier
font what is it doing
when when do we have captions in
graphics this is a plot
it does not have captions right
what happened here how did this not get
reviewed
uh yeah we'll take a look at that
you get get rid of it for 12.3 please
yeah
it was done for system modeler the
product
but somehow it snuck in here and it
shouldn't have snuck in here
okay
it's rather upsetting i hope that isn't
the case with all
system model plots that they've got this
garbage in them
uh no no no very few have captions
well let's get rid of them
get it correctly designed okay a little
surprised that this is just flatlining
there's nothing right so
they put it's like you're not giving it
any input to them
system so it's just isn't the default
to have these examples have input
well in this particular case we
definitely want because with the
controller we want to
add stuff we don't want the system to
have sources
so the two modes of thinking about this
steven so when you build a model
that sort of is complete it models
everything
then there is no such thing as what just
happened here what happened here i
thought this was a linearized version of
this system
why can't i plot it
well systematic doesn't process i
understand but that's wrong
okay why doesn't it process those things
it's supposed to be a system model i
just said linearize my system model
you got a transfer function i mean you
got a state space model back
which is not a system model okay but
that's that's you know that because
you're involved in implementing it
nobody else knows that so
this this function better start working
on things like these transfer functions
which it can do
right yes or let me or we can just
wrap create system model around it and
it'll work
great
so if i just say this here
yeah i think you also have to indicate
what to plot
oh okay because that's going to create a
model but then
now you have to you know okay all right
so you guys will figure this out
but the end result should be that these
things interoperate
that's what we're aiming for but this
this wasn't one we focus on now we'll
focus on that one also
okay but i need to explain one thing to
you just before we get too far off in a
tangent here
if you think of the system as a
completely modeled then the only thing
that you set
is typically initial values yes
okay that's not the case when you have
control
because you have effectively an unknown
input function
and you have to specify it and an
unknown intermediate input function as
in
okay yeah so so often people what they
do
for these systems that are controlled
they have control input they say
so how does it react if i send it a step
how does it react if i send it
a a ram or a sinusoid or something
so you see how it responds to different
kinds of input
a step response is sort of like the
simplest
you know that people often look at
okay so how do i do that in this case
for my electric filter how do i send it
to step
so you have to say input
i think it's down there if you go to the
to the right you can copy
yeah okay so here
what's the three number of seconds or
something yes
okay so if i say this and i say model
here
oops actually i don't want simulator i
want plot
so screw up but these things happen but
it shouldn't be allowed to happen
um okay in any case all right
fine great that's nice okay why does
that
i don't understand what the that's a
it's a pure function function
it's a pure function so i could say hash
three ampersand yeah f2 yeah
nice okay all right
good okay i think i understand that
now what now let's do this grand thing
okay so this is this is the controller
now okay i see but it's a controller
it's not controller data
uh as opposed to commander data or
anything like that
so when you then what the the the next
command what they will do
is to wire it up i i understand that i
understand it what i'm saying the point
that i'm making is
the thing you get out here is a
controller
no it's lots of things it's like
one of them is the controller but
that's that's like saying a classifier
there's lots of things you can get
okay let's review what we've done for
machine learning okay
you get out a classifier which can be
just applied to data
or you can say information of that
classifier comma or property
that's how you get out properties so
this one can't be applied to anything
meaningfully
okay except that it can be fed into
something
in the thing that you're about to do
here yeah it can be wired up to the
thing it was designed to
to right which means it's not really the
data it's really the controller itself
that's being wired up
that's right
okay so let's see what this wiring does
so progress monitor will be nice here
oh boy okay where is the controller here
it's okay so let me let me try to
understand i mean this is this is my
original
right the dc motor correct
yes okay so let's see can i even see the
motor
i don't understand anything yeah and by
the way why are these plots fuzzy why
are these things looking fuzzy are they
not vector graphics are they vector
graphics
um i don't think so
you do or do not
i think they're rasterized okay that's
not going to work
they should be vector graphics
right why why are they not vector
graphics they're clearly very vectorized
kinds of things
i don't think we could answer that very
easily right right away
okay all right fine okay so what is this
and what's its relationship to that
yeah okay i can because that the doubt
17 doesn't come out really well
but but what what you're seeing there is
that blocks
that block in the bottom that is the
controller
and that circle that you're seeing on
the left that is where the dc motor is
oh yeah i'm sorry i don't get this i i
added a controller
somehow i connected
a controller so i've got this model here
right yes
and i've got this how do i make a
picture of the controller is that yeah
so to see what the to see a clean
picture
we can see that in the in the
documentation for state feedback gains
new
so that that that is getting little
mangled up when it's coming in that
picture in out 17.
see that first illustration so there are
three components one is
that dc motor which is cis the other one
is the controller and then
the third one is the block that is
comparing the two signals
okay so they need icons and and this
thing here
which is in a lighted version of that
whole thing
which apparently is in unnamed models
and a weird uuid
i don't understand what's going on here
this is a dc motor and it's labeled
right
yes okay so why is that not a subpart of
this diagram here
yes yeah on in these class of
controllers are called state feedback
controllers and over here we have to
modify that model a little bit if you
look at that diagram on the left we had
to pull out those states from inside
so that's why we don't see the dc motor
like that
so what diagram on the left i mean i
don't know
on the right sorry on the right there is
the state feedback gains new
you see that x we are pulling it out
from inside cis so that's why that
the dc motor is not replicated there we
have to create another model
but in general very confused why don't
you just show a picture of this i will
be a lot less confused if they showed a
picture of this
even if it's just a thumbnail basically
showing that you're pulling this out of
it
do you understand what i'm saying yeah i
mean i i don't understand what you
this is totally confusing i mean this is
the input here is a solid arrow and the
output is a is a non-solid arrow
here it seems to be the other way around
etc
yeah this one needs some here what's
going on here look at this
this is totally fuzzy i don't understand
what this is
okay what does this picture this picture
should have
the dc motor in it there together with a
couple of additional components
one of which one of which includes
something with an icon that looks like
this presumably
right
so in that icon you see three things and
on the figure on the right in that
ref page also you see three things that
are the three things you see in out 17.
okay so this icon here is indicating
that what this
is is the blue thing in this diagram is
that correct
no no no yes yes yes this is the
controller
you just explained this to me this thing
here is the controller it's the k
here or a cap or whatever it is yeah
it's just the key that yes
yes okay so listen to what i'm saying to
you okay
you are indicating with this icon that
this is representing a controller
true or not true it's representing
a controller together with the plant
no no it's not this thing here
this controller data is representing the
data for the controller
you got it from well maybe it maybe it
is i i don't know actually okay so you
can
linearized okay you got it from this
linearized thing but this component
that's being represented here that's
then going to be connected in
is this thing is a controller that's
what this is supposed to be giving is
that not correct
i think i don't quite okay let's go
through it again
what you've got here it is but it
contains the following additional things
it actually also includes the plant
model that you gave as input i
understand it contains the linearized
plant
model yes because it needs that because
otherwise it can't work
exactly that is what a controller
okay there is the framework for a
controller
and there is the actual controller for a
particular system is that correct
yeah yes but it uses that to know where
to connect it up
when when connect system modeler connect
system model controller
goes to work it looks it up in there and
that's why it can work
in this one step thing otherwise you
would have half a page of code here
wiring it up
okay okay i understand so there's some
ports
that basically work exactly through yes
from the original so we've got the
original system model
somewhere up here okay
this original system model has certain
ports yes how would i see those ports
um you can there's one of the properties
of it yeah input variables
and so on it's a property called input
variables
and output variables and so on but
there's no display of the ports
there's nothing here no to me it would
be nice if there was a plus sign for
example
that would kind of show me a data set
that would would
interactively go from this diagram but
much like in the neural net case
we have that pretty nice click to drill
down type mechanism
yeah actually that's not a bad idea to
gradually
build out more of that stuff right but
so then then
okay so if we had click to drill down
one of the things you would see is the
list of
variables i mean we have a full-blown
modeling system so this is
i mean mathematic is sort of a junior
it's not a full you know we're not going
to build another modeling system
indeed
but i mean given given that you're
giving people the ability to
symbolically hook things up
i think you kind of need to tell them
yeah i think it's a pretty good idea
actually so
okay all right sergio do you take notes
okay okay so then
in what is it called input variables why
is there no auto completion here oh it
doesn't know what it is
okay okay does it show me at all where
that is
well okay that will be part of this this
interactive build out
okay so that's the input variable so
that then that's
wait a minute how is how is the wiring
up going to be down
yeah oh so so this model is very simple
there's only one input variable
and that's the input variable you see in
lin the v and that
so i can show you in the figure on the
on the right in the ref page
okay hold on hold on here we are showing
the input variable
yeah that just uh yeah although here
we're not showing the input variable
but with you don't always have input
variables
when you build as i said when you model
something
and it's supposed to model everything
yeah usually the only thing you have is
initial values
i understand when it's a subpiece of the
universe a subsystem then it'll have
initial
then it'll have input variables right if
it's something you're going to be able
to control then you need that
okay
okay so now this hookup
produced a system here
that has a uuid which is kind of
grotesque but
and i don't even think you should label
it given that it's a uuid
why would you want to put that label
there
uh well right now we require models to
have names
in system oiler but you don't have to
display it
okay that's true
yeah i wouldn't display it
okay i'm totally confused here
okay well i thought i thought you had
all the information from the original
system
which had been linearized well i still
need to send
and look at the the example where you
took it i can do system
model plot on this on the original model
right
you can do it on that one too if you
specify the input
let's go down
but i can just do system model plot
without specifying the input
right that's because the original model
had a store plot
uh so this new created model why not why
doesn't it
we cannot plus this yeah okay
oh okay so we had added default plots
right okay i can look at we had added
some default
something went wrong here just there are
default plots that should show up
we added them something went wrong okay
okay or maybe it's just maybe you just
have to add a time simulation time if
you just add like comma then
maybe that's enough
no yeah no okay we haven't fixed it yeah
there are default plots but
okay i can look into that okay fine
something went wrong
not a big deal okay so so let me just
walk through this again
so the basic the big point here is
that you have
connect system
controller this this relies on
if you if we didn't have all that
information in you what you have in
system auto controller data
this would have relied on you manually
knowing the topology of what to connect
i get it i get it i mean so my question
is
i'm thinking about the name of this
function uh okay
the parallel one to this is connect
system model components
and from there we have connect system
model controller
okay
okay so let's see how does this work
in a ways family is close to net graph
in which you have to specify all the
pieces and connections independently
right why is that model
brace model comma five why isn't that a
five what does that five mean there
in system model plots here
oh uh that's not necessary anymore yeah
that's uh
okay but what would it mean it used to
we used to have to put that parenthesis
there
in order to simulate first and then plot
but now it's not
necessary anymore okay so you change
this example right
yeah okay okay so
so
okay okay
so so would i be able to like
hook up you know this to like the
arduino stuff and things
and download some controller to my
uh yeah so two there's two interesting
scenarios to go there
one is that we have the microcontroller
kit and the controller you designed
will work excellently on an arduino not
oh
not
just work right away
the second thing is that we've also
arduino hook up the system model
um and that can also work
so you can have it hooked up there
what's the point of hooking it up there
i don't understand that one it's not as
much
of a point as accepted it's a nice
modeling environment
i see and it's it's super popular among
people people download we have a library
for that
and people get it and download it all
the time a lot
okay so
okay uh
some more questions how does this relate
to machine learning and particular
reinforcement learning stuff
so reinforcement is reinforcement
learning is sort of
i don't fully understand reinforcement
learning but i intend to get myself
up to speed of what works and what
doesn't there now
but reinforcement learning is sort of a
way and
a a way of doing control yeah
but it's not clear what works there and
what doesn't work
right now the examples that i've seen
are
a sort of very toy you know like
inverted pendulum and
that's what you do on day one in your
first
control theory 101. so it's not that
impressive
at this that stuff no but i understand
but i mean if you wanted to insert this
stuff so
we've got a way if i'm not mistaken to
insert a system model
in our reinforcement learning loop is
that true
um don't know about that i thought it
was the other way around
uh i mean we've talked about that but i
don't know that we have that in the ml
side fine
fine okay fine but so that's one goal is
to be able to learn
to use it as a um
what am i saying as a as a
thing that you're learning about so to
speak yeah yeah
absolutely that's that's that's one goal
but i don't think our reinforcement
learning has proceeded that far
yet um
and also one of the things that seemed
to have gone a lot farther is sort of
game play
rather than control yeah it's not
totally dissimilar but
apparently dissimilar enough
um what do you mean game oh you mean
yeah yeah right right i mean so this is
the case so there are
several different frameworks here so i
mean we have this thing with the
you know the open ai gym for example
using that
in the reinforcement learning loop right
so i don't know what tentacles that
thing has
that connect it to machine learning but
it will be good if they were compatible
now another thing that we have coming is
this virtual machine framework
which is very much a digital devices
framework
this is obviously an analog devices
framework mostly
that's another thing to point out
another question would be
um uh
what about um that game theory stuff
that we've been discussing
the others mentioned here on our live
stream about that
um what is the relationship between
these kinds of control things and the
game theory stuff
yeah so in a way when you design a
controller you could say that you play a
game
against an adversary which is like wind
and
you know these things that are called
noises that act on the system
and and and the controller has
this goal let's say of keeping your
speed constant
regardless of what your adversary like
the wind and the
um hills on the yeah the controller
represents a strategy in the game theory
sense
yeah and so the question is only a
plumbing question of can we insert one
of these controllers
i mean we have to design it i don't
think it's what we're looking at in
games here right now but i intend to
clarify that a little bit more okay but
that's not what we're aiming for in the
first round
it's it's a little bit you know just
matrix games basically
and stuff comment from 4d on the live
stream
do these play nicely with um uh
stochastic differential equations
um and for example our random process
stuff
not super well um
that's gonna to i mean
so they're both stochastic processes the
way that these control systems
are defined they are sort of a
specialized stochastic process
in the sense that we think of as
their linear systems with gaussian noise
so
um and the controllers that you design
are optimal
given that model of the world they are
the best you can do
given that horizon so they're called
linear quadratic gaussian
so for example let's say you have a boat
and i think the the spectrum of
waves water waves is like what is this
this piercing mosquito
spectrum or something yeah it's some
some spectrum of bumping up and down in
the ocean
yeah which presumably we can get from
our random process
subsystem right probably yes can we feed
that
into uh
um no no the control systems that
doesn't deal with sort of more
exotic models of of random processes
okay only quadratic only stochastic only
gaussian models
yes pretty much yeah the minute you go
to more advanced models you get into
this kind of optimal control that gets
um very untractable very quickly so the
of dimensionality is killing you usually
what is that just for my understanding
ito calculus is that all gaussian
no etho calculus is is
uh you know i mean
um e to calculus is what well let's put
it
it's the differentiation rules that you
have to use
for stochastic differential equations
by the way so just so i understand in
the case where you're loading this to an
arduino for example
so if i take a
microcontroller kit
yeah so what we would do is we would
look at that uh
that data object and ask i can't even
find
where is microcontroller kit you have to
search for micro well
i understand so this is a bug this is a
bug here's something
something micro controller is coming up
down there yes
but they're not the main ones yes
they're not the main ones no
there is the microcontroller kit guide
really amazing
okay but so so now which of these
functions so
i could take microcontroller embed code
so if i took
this controller wherever it is
where is it this is percent 16
is a controller okay so now i can say
microcontroller code data do i need to
say needs microcontroller kit
yes okay
so now i can say microcontroller code
data
no embed code okay
up percent 21.
so we need to pick out the actual
controller we need to pick out the
actual controller and then also say
to which pins of the microcontroller we
need to connect those why exactly is
this thing if it needs between two and
four arguments why isn't it giving red
carrot there
okay i'll look into that okay so what do
i what do i give here anyway
um
so i give a target here yes
okay and do you think i can use those
yes you can the first argument needs to
be modified too
how yeah you need to get out the
controller
feedback gains model that's the because
that that object contains lots of things
and you know
but so so this this should actually just
work right
microcontroller embed code should pull
out the thing it needs what do you need
what do i need to pull out here feedback
gains model
oh yeah we had to discretize that model
too because this is in continuous time
okay but so all of that stuff should
just happen right
now when we design the microcontroller
we also have to specify what
sampling we want how so all right so it
should pick a default
and give a message saying it picked such
and such default if it needed to do it
how do i do that how do i do the
discretization two discrete time model
yeah and then comma and give us maybe
point one
this is not a standard oh gosh why is
that a
and yet another nonsense yeah so this is
one i have to
get to okay that's super cool so now
those progress dialogues are just
getting finished
they can't be used until they're
finished okay all right how do i
actually see the code here
source code property from that is source
code
this is pretty impressive
it was a very simple controller how
could it be so simple
because it's just two gains
okay that's lovely now the other thing
that you want to do is why you want to
inject it back to system modeler
now the example that you took was a
particular simple model so it's actually
linear to begin with
but normally what you want to simulate
it and see
where the limits are
so so you kind of want to do a lot of
simulation work we're going to work on
more functions that makes that
much more streamlined going forward
it can be all done today but it can be
more streamlined
yes yeah so the typical workflows before
going to microcontroller embed code we
would take that
and go back to system modeler if it's a
non-linear model and then simulate it
and see if our controller is good
and after some iterations then choose a
sampling period and come yeah that's
nice i mean this stuff is all has a
certain degree of complexity and that
and i don't know to what extent you're
giving people workflows where they can
just fill in the
different steps presumably you've got a
bunch of sample notebooks and so on that
show
all the sequence of steps that are
needed right yeah and workflows written
we're writing workflow literally
workflows
so i know we need to rap here in a
moment but but um on our live stream
for these commenting that um one thing
point out is that when you link machine
learning to process control
is that you can't extract the physics of
a well-controlled system
because obviously you're living in the
regime where little of the physics is
visible right
what if you have a well-controlled
system
right you're living in that domain where
the thing is linear in its responses
and presumably that there are i mean
it's an interesting question whether i
don't know i mean so here's how you
actually do it
when you're trying to figure out the
sort of a plant model how do you model
it from raw physics like system modeler
secondly is that you can maybe use black
box models and the neural networks is an
example of a black box model but
typically
more easier ones the way you then do
that
is that you send a bunch of signals to
the system and let it respond
yeah okay and that whole discipline is
called system identification
right it's a whole big field in its own
right
it's very well developed
yep
fair enough okay well good this is all
this um this looks
very impressive and large system here um
i mean i okay this business about
systems model
versus system model you know that needs
to get figured out
right our plan is to gradually
you know smooth out all of these
workflows
and build towards higher and higher
level functionality
and higher levels of automation which
means that we'd be accessible to more
and more people
including you stephen yes well that
would be good i've never used this stuff
right i'm i'm looking forward to using
it i was going to use it on some whole
hvac system but i don't think it ever
happened that way
um wait a minute is the risk v
architecture included in the compiler
options here
no risk be um
it could be in the future uh but
microcontroller kit is compiling to
microcontrollers
each one of those provide
the ones that we support provide
basically the compilers
compiler stack um
risk v is
not yet you know i mean it's getting
there but it's not yet that that sort of
stage of heavily used but i think it's
it has a very good chance of getting
there
and and there's no reason why we
couldn't add
risk fee in the future to
microcontroller kit monitor supported
okay we should wrap it up here good
stuff
and uh for those who are following live
streams we collided with another live
stream so
we'll be a few minutes here and then we
will be talking about
discrete computation part two right and
roger i think you're in that one as well
yep okay so see